sometimes there are movies that get a
small release and they're good movies
and I miss out on them but then Oscar
season comes around these movies get a
lot of buzz and then they get a wider
release now I get to check them out and
see what I've been missing which is
apparently a lot silver linings playbook
so silver linings playbook stars
Jennifer Lawrence and Bradley Cooper and
it's ultimately a dramedy Bradley Cooper
just gets out of the feed farm because
he kind of lost his [ __ ] he lost his
cool and he did something now he's been
in therapy because he's bipolar and then
he gets out and he meets Jennifer
Lawrence who is also bipolar and I gotta
say this is the most accurate and
realistically relatable by polar
representation I've ever seen in a movie
you always hear about bipolar people
then you watch this movie and you're
like I know a couple of bipolar people
so you watch this movie and you watch
these people interact and you're like oh
this is enjoyable and relatable
remarkably relatable and as much as
everyone loves this movie it gets you to
think maybe we all have a bit of crazy
in us it's not just that it's like
everyone in this movie has a social
aspect to them that is flawed like
really flawed like in to the point where
you're like psychologically speaking you
have an issue then you realize you're
like but that's like this person I know
or that's like that person I know
or that's like me that's really what I
can say about this movie this movie
makes you go man kind people we're all
just a bunch of nuts trying to make our
way in the world some more crazy than
others but ultimately yeah we're all
just kind of nuts
however for Jennifer Lawrence I was like
yeah you're kind of crazy and bipolar
but you know I think it's workable you
start making excuses because when that
chick is playing bipolar you start going
okay you know I can work with this
though if you ask me ask me it's fine
it's fine it's fine
she's never been hotter and that's what
I'm saying and that's the baffling part
about it as much as I don't put up with
weird drama and as crazy as she is I'm
looking at her in this movie going I can
deal with that but I really couldn't she
would annoy the [ __ ] out of me we want
to talk about supporting actors stealing
the show holy [ __ ] Robert De Niro you
know De Niro he's just kind of he's
DeNiro now you put tenir on the movie
now and he's just like the point is you
know he's just he's Robert De Niro he's
gonna be good and he's going to be De
Niro but this movie is one of those
movies where he's like no sometimes you
got to take the kids to school let me
show you how a Supporting Actor
and in this movie he's OCD you know
everything has its system and he's just
like no it this has to be this and then
he overreacts and he starts putting it
on Bradley Cooper's shoulders you get to
walk out of this movie going hey I know
three bipolar people all right it's not
even a bad thing you can go to them and
be like there is a reason you annoy me
I actually have a reason now you're
bipolar I'm giving you a break by
telling you that and then they'll get
pissed at you and and punch you because
that's what Jennifer Lawrence would do
in this movie that's how I know that
silver linings playbook was heartfelt
the interaction between the characters
is fantastic real and relatable and the
dialogues really good it's one of those
movies I can't think of a lot of
negatives to say about the movie in fact
I don't think I can think of any
negatives this movie would have been on
my top ten of the year it's like the
50-50 of this year only thing I saw it
in January now so it's that's done
there's no going back and I don't look
back I just I move on I press on with
life excelsior
and all I loved about this movie and
walked away going that was genuinely
good I gotta say silver linings playbook
is awesome tacular so what's your
favorite dramedy not quite comedy now
quite drama dramedy you know like the
heartfelt movie that has a humor in it
and it's you connect with it and it's
nice it's not boring a [ __ ] although you
think it should be whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you